ha llegado la presentación en la cual
vamos a demostrar el cambio de base de
los logaritmos déjame ponerlo aquí el
cambio de base a la fórmula del cambio
de base la fórmula del cambio de base
que decía más o menos así si yo me tomo
el logaritmo en base a de supongamos no
sé x de variable x esto es exactamente
igual y podemos cambiar de base el
logaritmo podemos decir que esto es
igual a quien a tomarnos el logaritmo en
una distinta base vamos a suponer la
base ve fíjate como estoy cambiando de
base el logaritmo en base b de x de la
variable que está en el logaritmo entre
el logaritmo en base de ojo estoy
cambiando de base por lo tanto tengo que
cambiar de base tanto arriba como abajo
el logaritmo en base b de a y muy bien
yo lo que quiero es probar esta fórmula
pero recuerdas que yo te decía que esta
fórmula es bastante importante y de
hecho bastante útil en toda la vida
cotidiana sobre todo cuando se nos
presenta un problema de logaritmos
y yo te ponía por ejemplo no sé el
logaritmo en base vamos a poner otra
base en base 3 de 25 de 25 el logaritmo
en base 3 de 25 yo te decía que no todas
las calculadoras tienen esta propiedad
la propiedad de sacar el hogar en uno
base 3 de 25 sin embargo podríamos
cambiar de base no se base el logaritmo
natural o logaritmo en base a 10 las
cuales son las clases más utilizadas y
me quedaría se utilizó el logaritmo en
base 10 el logaritmo en base 10 de 25
sobre el logaritmo en base 10 de 3 esto
utilizando la fórmula del cambio de base
de logaritmos pero será cierta esta
fórmula de cambio de base y lo que
quiero hacer ahorita es demostrarte la
fórmula del cambio de base así que
déjame poner aquí primero el logaritmo
en base a de x y vamos a bautizar a esto
porque lo voy a utilizar bastante como
lo voy a bautizar como la variable ya
entonces voy a decir que logaritmo en
base a de x es igual de bien esta parte
de aquí es igual al yen y vamos a ver
que llegamos a continuación lo que
quiero que veas es que esto
exactamente lo mismo o es equivalente a
pensar de forma exponencial es decir ha
elevado la potencia y esto es igual a
equis recuerda que estas dos expresiones
significan lo mismo pero voy a poner la
x hasta acá porque ahorita voy a
trabajar con ambas partes entonces
fíjate bien voy a poner la x hasta acá y
yo tengo que ha elevado la ye es igual a
equis porque estoy diciendo exactamente
lo mismo que está aquí arriba logaritmo
en base a de x es igual a jane es la
expresión equivalente ahora qué te
parece si tomo el organismo en base ve
en mi nueva base de ambos lados de la
ecuación me queda el logaritmo en base
de a elevado al aiem es igual a
logaritmo en base pe de x lo que estoy
haciendo de un lado a los 3 t2 de otro y
por lo tanto se sigue manteniendo la
igualdad sin embargo hay una propiedad
de los logaritmos que dice que los
exponentes bajan multiplicando el
logaritmo recuerdas es decir esto lo
quedaría como james la potencia baja que
multiplica a logaritmo en base b de lo
único que ustedes en los bajando la
potencia por la propiedad de los
logaritmos que bajan las potencias estas
dos cosas son iguales y del otro lado
tengo que esto es lo mismo que el
logaritmo en base
de x aquí no voy a hacer nada porque de
hecho no tengo ninguna propiedad que me
digan nada al respecto pero bueno
logaritmo en base b de x y bueno qué te
parece si resolvemos esta ecuación para
ella es decir vamos a despejar ayer de
esta ecuación porque yo sé cuánto vale
gemma así que déjame despejar para ello
y para esto lo que me estorba es el
logaritmo en base de pda entonces qué te
parece este dividido a ambos lados de la
ecuación entre el logaritmo en base de a
entonces déjame ponerlo aquí aquí voy a
dividir entre el logaritmo en base b de
am y del otro lado también voy a dividir
entre el logaritmo en base de a a y esto
de utilizar muchos colores es bastante
cansado pero eso sí no puedes decir que
no está quedando bastante colorido y
bastante entretenido este vídeo y bueno
estos dos se van logaritmo en base a
entre el organismo en base de am se van
y simple sencillamente me queda que ya
es igual a am y voy a copiar todo esto
que tengo aquí en lugar de escribirlo
todo con todos los colores mejor voy a
copiar
así que déjame cortarlo copiarlo y
pegarlo perfecto y lo voy a poner aquí y
mejor lo voy a poner un poco para acá
porque lo que quiero es esta igualdad
recuerdas pero recuerda que yo sé cuánto
vale
james bien lo tenemos aquí arriba vale
igual al logaritmo en base a de x esto
de aquí este ejemplo pierde pegarlo lo
que vale ya es justo como habíamos
definido ayer desde un principio aquí lo
tenemos y es igual al hogar en base a de
x y esto es igual a quien a pues por lo
que acabo de llegar a logaritmo en base
btx entre logaritmo un base b de amd es
decir nuestro cambio de base y ya está
era justo lo que queríamos